o meu nome é maria falha como a nossa
apresentadora já disse sou formado em
psicologia e gradualmente foi se
especializando empreendedorismo social e
trap parte a este sou eu
tem vindo a saltitar e por todos os
países que também já foi dito aqui a
desenhar e implementar programas de
saúde mental em situações de crise
humanitária que embora possa por ser
dramático e fazer uma tese para fora da
crise sofrimento nos dias que correm é
como diz a minha prima as ficções ótico
preocupação por todos estes países na
cimbal líbia síria e ucrânia já o sudão
do sul índia e cachoeiras e então é só o
sessões atlético optou também por não
vir falar destes 50 mil e 150 milhões de
deslocados de guerra
olhos nos 220 mil mortes na síria 12 mil
são crianças ou até dos 350 milhões de
pessoas registradas com as pressões o o
mal estar psicológico porque os times
neste número de noticiário sempre uma
distanciaram do essencial sempre
distanciaram das pessoas
os agentes continuaram gostava de vos
pedir que ouvissem estes podem sair boy
alguém me consegue dizer o que sente uma
só palavra do corpo boa mas allen não
seja um time como o desespero medo como
volta mas alguém tome time tite já sei
que os homens não choram as minhas não
repassarmos fala que sentiram tristeza a
angústia alguém fico extremamente feliz
com essa pessoa podemos combinar uma
consulta psicológica assim ele ficou
apaixonado
pois bem é exatamente disso que vos
venho falar hoje de emoções porque é
exatamente esta característica que nos
distingue enquanto ser humano se nos
permite ter de ser resilientes e
adaptáveis e até sobreviver às condições
mais humanas que podemos encontrar
panfletos mas como não gosto de access
escolhi apresentar três pessoas
fantásticas que conheceu ao longo do meu
percurso e pelo fundo ajudaram a
valorizar esta minha intervenção é eo
meu mais recente trabalho que você
apresente mais à frente
as fotografias que vos apresento não são
das próprias pessoas mas representam um
carinho os ambientes onde estas pessoas
se encontravam e esta é uma das
primeiras esta esta fotografia traz
melhor lembra o momento em que eu
conheci o atleta
o argumento era um líder de um grupo
armado e eu conhecia o porto fã eu digo
nervoso uma manhã dizendo existir falar
contigo um líder de um grupo armado
eu não sei se vocês já tiveram passaram
por este tipo de convite mas quando isto
acontece é claramente o caiu o primeiro
é a minha boca estava no médio oriente
por segmento encontraram com ele
encontrou na manhã seguinte tinha
acabado de chegar da linha da frente e
basicamente recebeu de um chá enquanto
limpava as armas do que trazia da linha
da frente neste momento eu disse mas eu
estou muito zangado contínuo desde que
cheguei a esta região toda a gente fala
assim eo pior nos falando do mesmo
suas vem falar de paixões paradas pela
guerra
sabe o que isso paixões para é vamos
falar também de expressas de angústias
desta questão da família é essen como
ativo eu tenho as pessoas do meu grupo
falaram sobre isto e o pior não é esse o
efeito que não deixa mesmo em gado é o
facto de o próprio da por mim é chorar
quando equaciono o facto de enviar o meu
filho de apenas 12 anos para a linha da
frente provando para levantar os corpos
os corpos que estão nos escombros
será que eu tenho que ser como é que eu
vou conseguir abraçar a minha é a minha
guerra se eu continuar a ter as
desilusões e foi aí que nós curamos o
quereres do adversário emocional e
quixadá e puxar a explorar mas eu quero
esta questão da regulação das emoções de
moda que não impedissem a nossa própria
performance
o haxixe foi outra pessoa extremamente
importante tanto que eu conhecia e eu
conheci o enquanto dava uma exceção do
grupo
os dois grupos desse tipo construído com
contextos basicamente vai entrar nos
sonhos vem com alguns tipos de
sofrimento e foi curioso porque o caxito
consolação por me dizer olha eu estou
felicíssimo acabou de chegar da linha da
frente e fui realizar os meus sonhos da
minha vida fui pai de uma criança vinda
a maioria não tem seis meses e é este
que foi o que eu sempre desejei na vida
mas neste momento eu gostava de pedir
para usar um dos benefícios é um dos
privilégios que eu tinha que vai perder
na guerra direito à privacidade preciso
falar com cinco continuações de claro e
e quando nos encontrarmos na numa sessão
individual eu desabafou chorando que
sinto extremamente culpado porque não
estava a conseguir cumprir o que havia
pedido o que vi por um tiro à sua mulher
dez anos antes quando se casaram eu
perguntei pra dormir actor me abraçado a
ela até o resto das suas vidas neste
momento como tinha sido baleado no braço
não conseguir não conseguir dormir
abraçado a ela tenha essas dores
eu sentia extremamente culpado e
frustrado com a incapacidade conseguir
cumprir este estes
vejo que ela lhe prometera foi que
juntos exploramos diferentes formas de
expressão de afeto diferentes formas de
provar o amor a eds e demonstrações de
ambos a mim é que eu conhecia insistir
numa das cidades líbias
uma semana antes do kadafi ter sido
apanhado e morto junto ao desgosto aos
votos do hospital que nós visitamos foi
uma visita intensa nós estávamos no meio
da linha da frente o hospital tenha sido
seqüestrado e basicamente 9 não tinham
acesso à água assim o saneamento ou até
a a aditamento da equipa cirúrgica não
funcionava por isso toda a população que
estava dentro do hospital estava naquele
momento sem acesso aos serviços de saúde
eu cheguei com psicóloga equipa médica
que não tem a sua função e como
psicóloga cabe me fazer o levantamento
das necessidades e identificar quais são
os sintomas que as pessoas podem estar a
passar a sentir efetivamente fazer
primeiros corpos e colagens
naquele momento eu consegue fazer o que
tinha que fazer os bombardeamentos eram
extremamente forte e por isso sempre que
vê um bombardeamento o edifício estranho
se a determinada altura percebi que
estou a ser escoltada não era por nenhum
grupo armado era pela mina
uma menina de 7 anos que 18 neste
momento não pode continuar sem vir
conhecer a minha mãe faz questão
companhias conhecer a minha mãe e eu
vamos até a maca da mãe dela
quando cheguei lá e ele me apresentei é
a mina não deixou terminar isso então
fantástico e estamos aqui para ajudar
vai ser comigo vai ter que me ajudar a
vir até o sítio nestas com bomba tentou
argumentar porque é exatamente aí que os
meus irmãos de 3 e 5 anos ficaram quando
eu e minha irmã eu e minha mãe tivemos
que fugir
e por que ela estava ferida não tivemos
que não conseguimos trazê los ao colo
sozinhas ou que não conseguir os carros
mas contínuo contigo estão sendo duas
conseguimos conseguir trazê las ajuda e
foi isso que esperamos esta questão da
importância que têm os outros nossas
vidas
questões relacionadas com medo com as
cidades e conseguimos certa forma dar
ali controle aquela situação
o que todas estas pessoas têm em comum e
ea razão pela qual hoje pelas quais as
razões pelas quais eu os trouxe é o
facto de tudo não ser a situação a
diversão de se encontram clientes
impossibilita darem a volta ao texto
todas elas estão realmente preocupadas
com os outros e com a sua relação com os
outros e acima de tudo e tiveram a
capacidade de conseguir regular as
emissões que surgiam durantes a situação
e tudo isto tiveram apoio no momento
certo
foram também estas pessoas que nos
levaram a desenvolver o meu mais recente
trabalho e acreditar verdadeiramente que
todos nós tivermos um que deixou estas
funções ou não até sexy
conseguimos certa forma promover mais
bem estar não só em nós como as pessoas
que nos rodeiam
basicamente os estudos indicam que uma
das maiores causas da depressão ademais
de mal estar psicológico é a sensação de
que nós não só não estamos não temos
amigos verdadeiros
esta é uma das frases mais comuns e por
isso eu acredito que se cada um de nós
quando conseguir construir o seu próprio
tipo de emoções disse estas emissões
conseguirá criar certa forma uma
conta-poupança dimensões prazerosas que
nos possibilita é a sina que podem ser
acionados quando estamos confrontados
com situações de crise adversas nas
nossas vidas
neste kit o que é importante é que cada
um consiga reconhecer e identificar e
monotorizar quando nos sentimos bem
quando nos sentimos mal
quantas vezes passam seis meses sem
sabermos o que estamos a sentir e
demoramos a dar uma resposta em termos
de las é vender sem utilização
conseguiremos dar uma resposta mais
rápida neste que é importante também
aprender a identificar sinais de alerta
é muitas vezes temos nossas estamos já
atingimos o nosso limite e não
conseguimos estancar a linha situação
porque não conhecemos os nossos próprios
sinais de alerta é importante conhecê
los
neste kit e acima de tudo é identificar
o bandaid emocionais também a sexo e
nome e basicamente bandai de quantas
- temos situações adversas já uma cela
sem opcionais a mãe deixou de falar o
namorado terminou um divórcio um ano ou
uma morte isto é uma mazela num sinal se
nós tivermos um bandeirante que já temos
dentro de nós adicionamos conhecemos
poder estancar esta frieza emocional que
conseguiremos certa forma dar uma volta
mais eficaz à situação e acima de tudo
esta questão da das fontes de bem-estar
uma uma vez esta esta história da
felicidade e da harmonia vem sempre como
um produto final e raramente damos
importância de adriano hoje no aquino
agora é e o fato é que conseguimos
identificar fontes também estar para o
nosso dia-a-dia permitir nos a viver
hoje aqui agora de uma forma bastante
mais prazerosa e tudo isto se tivermos
mais bem-estar seremos como dizem os
mais criativos mais produtivos mais
resiliente e acima de tudo conseguiremos
ter melhores relações com os outros
abraçar o que eu acredito é nossa a
nossa responsabilidade universal de
promover o nosso bem estar e dos que nos
rodeiam contribuindo assim para
sociedades mais harmoniosas menos
agressivas mais simpáticas e acima de
tudo mais humanas não só para nós conta
as gerações futuras os nossos filhos que
vai